enjoy it it's gonna be about the
interactions between a statistic /
learning theory and an optimization
since the recent years those
interactions are really gone both ways
right so statistics and learning are
provides a new set of problems for
Malaysian people and in the other way
around the optimization algorithm and
proof I've given you no new perspective
on learning and statistics present so we
will see examples of both of this
direction and sometime we need to think
about both the statistical and the
optimization point of view together so
we will see all of that basically one
important thing that I want to say that
we have an open forum session on
Thursday afternoon at 3:30 p.m. and I
and the organizer really would like this
to be successful so we'll put together a
Google document you will receive an
email with the link and I will when we
are doing every write up on the board
also so that you can sign up so just put
a title for your open program and your
name and you know we will put together a
schedule so we are not interested in
incremental problems you know like that
the last line that you put in your paper
you just not the problem that we are
looking for we're looking for something
maybe a bit border bit different from
what you have been doing in the past so
I and we understand that you can be
worried about credit in those cases so
the understanding is that if you mention
an open paren then and somebody is
interested in working on it it will
reach out to you and try to work with
you in the case that you know six months
later somebody solves it by themselves
and you know if you were not included
they will happily credit you maybe put
your name in the title or something like
that so really don't be shy about giving
good problem we will try to work
together okay so I think that's all I
wanted to say and I'm very happy to have
to introduce in yet for the first dog
who is going to talk about raava
stochastic and online optimization yeah
my name is a year and thanks to
organizers a passing and do business or
opportunity talk about the some of the
work in the connection between
uncertainty and organization
so I'm also use these fancy words called
data-driven organization in fact any
word position pub which would have be
data-driven anyway so I'm associated
with Stanford University and you know I
CME and MSE so this is my outline I just
wanted to say what is the give a very
brief introduction what is the
distribution is robusta correlation all
this is the underlying I'm the
stochastic organization which data come
from uncertainties okay so and I'm
pretty quickly to talk about and dro and
the moment and some kind of a likelihood
bounce okay then i'm talk about the
price of correlations many many times
and we don't know what the you know
distribution we just assume the other
random variable independently so what a
price you can pay and what kind of
optimization problem that's actually is
the safe assumption whatever then
finally i'm talk about online in your
organization and so and also ready to
dynamic venom so all this relate to some
kind of a stochastic decision estimation
optimization problems where actually you
don't know precisely what distribution
would be so so you relax that and then
hopefully you still make safe decisions
the whole goal is try to develop some
tractable and provable models and arms
and with uncertain online data so that's
the theme of the work so let me give a
very introduction so all this doesn't
matter what's the action amazing
organization decision problems so
typically your face
something and the your decision
variables plus some kind of an uncertain
data's okay here I could see and what we
do is we typically assume and the C come
from certain distribution with the
distribution functions then we take
expected in the value so this is a
typically and in the old days of people
is not like human Tori supply chain and
all the data exclamation so we do this
kind of a stochastic optimization okay
we're assume this decision variable come
from some kind of a decision space we
could capital X and C represent some
random variables okay with this
distribution so this is a has we used of
many years and the expected values good
measure of the performance okay but the
cons is one has to know exact the
distribution and to perform this
stochastic optimization and from Psalms
you've however if the decision in the
90s Yogi's run then you have a garbage
in garbage out so this is a problems in
many many practical patience you may not
know exactly what's the distribution
function other ways to do this is
completely so-called robust okay so you
minimize excess so you just a finding
what's the support of your uncertain
data then you assume your the bursaries
I just choose a single and point
distribution and to minimize this
function you want to be in them you're
going to maximize and this is change the
settings to maximize anyway so this is
kind of a game kind of a models which
were usually called robust okay so this
is a robust to any distribution okay
because you just pick a single and
element from this support set such that
these functions minimized okay the
counts and these were too conservative
you
and many many statistical information
and data behavior which is not utilized
so this has been and many authors
already talked about this to
conservative level so so here come to
the middle ground so in practice we may
not know distribution but we do know
some kind of samples or training data or
statistics informations management
actually mentions so how would cooperate
those information the beauty is kind of
for an intermediate approach okay so be
turn stochastic which is the could be
two risk and also has no job astok but
also another extreme kind you have this
robust ik organization so here comes
what we called distributional robusta
coop temptation okay so what's the
decision with us organization qulity our
own so what we do is we assume we don't
know exactly distribution what it is
okay but however we may have some
support or constraints and those
possible distributions so we minimize
still expect the value for any possible
distribution in this D then and then we
we assume this is still kind of a three
but now and your adversary's not cinco I
choose a single thing to hurt you but
you have to choose certain distributions
and those distribution and have some
constraints so this is a core D are all
so in the past ten years and we have
been no try to analyze this model at a
time where we were sinking should we
call the statistically robust relation
with distribution or robust to
coordination or something so we decide
maybe we just caught distribution of
robust so and so the question is so how
to choose
so we have to choose indeed we have to
say make the model to be tractable so
hopefully we can still solve and faster
and theoretical may be important on your
time ones those kind of things okay and
also you do have a practical status
Khomeini's and finally of course
practical performance does that make
sense so there was many many work come
out of course everything has a history
so this kind of approach actually for
single variables where was was actually
introduced by scarf and organise the
inventory problems and they can use when
their problems then many many organized
sometimes this problem is not tractable
when you have a multi variables ok so we
start working some seven to prove
certain models can be solved in
polynomial time then there was many many
way to discuss the how to construct the
D the possible distribution if you have
likelihood distribution you have a
divergence then you have I'm going to
list a few of these and there was a time
and big reset this is all achieved and
they also found a very rich connection
to machine learning and this kind of
things came a Markov decision process
then some on dominga the dispersant and
we also then this is a paper people
consider distribution said just assume
they are independent so instead of multi
variables and instead of finally join
the variance they just forget it they
just use marginals and assumes it's a
product distribution so we'll talk about
some of this so application in many
areas ok I'm going to briefly mention
some of these so I'm going to briefly go
through very simple and the so called
the moment and likelihood bands okay so
what's the probability D so as I said
everything come down and on D so given
pause
Paul and sample variance okay given
possible sample mean so this is the
model we construct for all the
distribution of course they have to you
know add up equal to one for some
flexible just consider this is discrete
okay so the expected value and the
Muslim mean and this is the cheapest
basically build a Euclidean Bowl such
that the mean value cannot be divergence
from new 0 too much okay
and also the covariance matrix of the
two distribution and it should be less
than some kind of a sample experience by
some lambda 2 so the question is how do
the way how to choose number one and
number two those two scalars control how
tight those distribution would be okay
so this is a diffusion all the division
has to be satisfy those constraints like
okay so this is what they're so this
distribution said is fine based on
support okay
and also forced moment and also second
award moment constraints basically
so the question is given such a D so we
have this is a matrix inequalities
basically says this is a matrix has to
be lesser than this number two could be
a scalar because an one that's the
sample variance so this symbol means
this matrix subtract by this matrix it's
positive semi definite so it's not you
can't consider this is a matrix
confidence intervals okay
and it's just a standard confidence
interval for Marty kind of decision
variables so okay so now first under
this D the distributive lattice which we
talked about can be solvable yes and so
this is a first theorems to handle
Martin kind of uncertainties dimensional
uncertainties but however constructed
this distribution in robust model to
prove the problem is polynomially
solvable at specter is it's the use of
son semi definite programming and plus
some other complex organization
technology H oh yes this is a function
which is that has a certain technical
some shins for example is contacting the
eggs some certain concavities in the sea
and also may be much boughs and the sun
sea yes basically say if we fix the sea
and the problems for longer solve all
under these uncertainties expected
watching also polynomial so you choose
two different sigma naught from the
first moment condition the second moment
condition first moment oh yes I think
it's a tutu
yes you basically say this to zero may
not be the same for this one yes I think
the still two singers do - yeah
basically this is this is just a convex
regions and this is just a matrix
inequalities if you use different the
matrix I think it's due to
but here we just use the same thing
because we you know and variants then
okay so this retractable the SEC
repressions does this confidence
intervals first or the second one when
the mid made the statistical sense may
be related to questions yes it's just
consider these assumed use yellow and
Sigma 0 which is the verb is the
covariance matrix point X mate and
excavator from the empirical data for
example size M and C this is a big
series it's just the support is bounded
okay so you can choose R 1 R 2 then you
can prove the true distribution it is
not in these come kind of a country
region with high probability so that's
just standard basically we extended the
confidence intervals to matrix
confidence intervals and with these
matrix inequality so that makes sense
so here conserve sample size yes the
dimension of size
the mention of the sigh in this
particular case is not the dependent on
the dimension size may choose gamma1
gamma2
I have to go back to check as far as
this condition satisfied
yeah so this is a so this is a so-called
confidence intervals so so it's
tractable and also and test on many many
portfolio whatever and the experiment
seems of performant and reasonable well
okay this is the one way to use moment
information to construct the D of course
yes technically you also get a lower
bound right for yes that's right no
proof if you use that that's the np-hard
problems okay so basically say we think
we just photo relax yeah terribly your
conference tour and covariance matrices
sure that you also have low abundance
correct but the random as you have done
once and you have the problem become and
be hard especially for mati and the C
dimensional however this basically we
removed that lower Banach and matrix
inequalities make them need a bit of
logic the D so it's a little bit more
conservative in some sense good question
yeah of course many many way maybe not
even by a moment we just given some
observe the data then we just define
under C again probability measure equal
to one and then we construct some
likelihood functions okay so so this
basically say it's a likelihood function
has to be greater than sum again adjust
you know never of confidence okay so
this is for example you assume support
uncertainties highlight you only have
impossible realizations so you observed
am i samples with Sigma I so am i were
to be your sample distribution so the
reasonable max likelihood functions
would be just a my log p IP represent
your true and thirty students
that's possible and probability so this
is a sense so this Mexican factions and
it's greater than gamma of course and in
practice you adjust what's the gamma is
the reason about the tolerance and to be
natural pasta was thrown into a bust
okay so this is another way to do this
okay this is what's there now you can
again analyze lot of us that is to go
related to divergence and you know how
to activate by samples confidence of the
truth distribution use to collect all
the theory relate to Owen and
sympathetically Rees and the prospects
tends to do with also continuous case so
that's one way basically given you have
a finite realizations you do
distribution sample sample and the
distribution then you want the true
distribution the Mac likelihood to be
under certain level so that's a lot way
to do it okay and also there was another
way a third way to do with code the way
certain and kind of a distance between
two distribution so this to using can be
expressed as the minimum cost of moving
one to other which turn out if you used
a one and cost and this is basically
become the same interpret any
programming problems so in this case and
you basically say and this is the sample
distribution to distribution you want
this distance to be less than some Sigma
level that this on the line this
function actually is the minimum value
of a linear programming problems it's
convex as this basically Bay
couple people and especially Kong and
there's a curve a final example
guarantee you can prove correct for
ability is high with n sample speak and
you can prove the tool as can go to you
fit key
steerer unbiased goes to one okay and
then you also say this complexity
our objective function is convex
function some lot of things happens and
you have a same computational complexity
as the simple sample average approach so
yeah this is just the movie you can
think about firelight yeah this is
computational complexity is it sa-ay for
that problem can be solved faster this
was also so fast but it's need for more
conservative its computational time
boundaries that say so specifically this
is a suppose you know many people use
logistic regressions okay so basically
you have this form and so basically T
are all suggest usual somehow in that
Western uncertain he said it's called
ambiguity said you mean in the soup of
this logistic regression place with some
logistical agent data have some some
certainties and I believe and then and
you know with n reduce actually and rich
connection to these kind of Rabbis
logistic regression level I believe
young also did work in this one I so
they passed this and this dependent on
what's the cost you're going to use and
the different law may have a different
norm regularity so anyway so this is the
trend sometimes instead just use few
stochastic elimination you build a
little bit uncertainty
somehow the curvature relate to certain
regularity and objective which is
popularly also used now you find a new
interpretation what means to recognize
the and regression
okay so this is the summary and Aldo
provide the solutions okay attractable
sometimes maintains the same computation
of complexity which is stochastic
presumably you load the distribution
here you assume you don't know this
diversion and it's very many problems
okay so that's the PIO
turn out to be and the represent a lot
for the decision problem of estimation
problems so now I'm going to talk about
the price of a correlation especially
the high dimensional uncertainty so so
this is particularly choose this just at
some possible for example portfolio
optimization problems or could it be
facility location where demand so most
of our code to some discrete
optimization and how to build
uncertainty is certain discrete
optimization facility location but I
have a man many demand demand is
uncertain okay again it's the own
particularly concerned about to see is
the very very high dimension of course
so comments which is again sample
average but however when the size the
dimension of free increased a usual is
the sample size would be also increased
dramatically so this is a theoretically
you can say dementia increased a sample
size necessary to make accurate
acceleration is also increased
exponentially so this is a way you
decode curse dimensionality okay so yes
require simple size to do what so I
created a ionized moment and all the
moment information the bin and and also
covariance those can see
especially co-variants so then we we
basically say well is this particular
problem safe suppose I only know
marginal distributions
I don't exit coherence so what I'm going
to do is I'm just assume the
distribution is is the is yeah so
basically assume is the product the
distributions
okay I so 400 basically I'm soon as a
random variable independent so I don't
need to analyze the covariance so we're
still maximize this with the P okay and
of course you don't know if Joint
Distribution say red code you need to do
the alter Joint Distribution to
understand and this your fan also joined
the pollution function density functions
right here so what do we do with just
product marginals so what's the risk
associated with assume independence can
we analyze risk in terms the property of
objective functions again and what kind
of functions assume independence is the
safe Theo I mean basically I need to if
you assume this is a normal distribution
you know the covariance generally we
just need to excavate join the
distribution that's the sample size
which are talked about
so we codify this risk it's called the
price of correlation because we relax we
assume they are independent then we have
to pay some price okay so and so this is
a we analyze and for what functions this
price is not too high for what function
this price it is very high so at least
in practice thanks when all what's the
credit problems we know whence the
safely for simplicity computation know
for when computable can we and can we
safely assume this Jennifer product
distribution so here's the definition
with the price I'm still use this
distribution model assume X star is
converted this completely zone assume
you know the join the distribution okay
here I'm soon you only use a product
distribution so so basically say and the
probability for idea whatever is just a
product of those probabilities okay then
we consider this okay this is a max over
all the possible distribution estimate
at X star so this X hat is the one only
x2 mated and join the distribution so
this is a minimizer cost the problems so
this number will be bigger than one okay
was I restrict only to these two joint
the distribution so how higher would it
be even on what's the objective
functions
sometimes we'll code a correlation gap
okay it's the concept okay so yes good
okay so many many stochastic specially
independent entities version get
approximate solutions okay
basically because much much easy to
solve
okay a once your known independence and
also capture value innovation so if we
say we have approvable plc smaller it's
not to raise kudos from independence
okay large would it be and assume you
need really that know the koreans
covariance we tend to random variables
so in the nam chao for basically say if
the function is supper modulo then
usually need a small POC if function
super modular live to large POC it's the
super modular in terms of uncertainty
variables because your function is also
part of this okay so what's the
sub-module so in some sense you can
think about this function for any fixed
X is the function of a see okay so
what's the super sub modulo it's
basically a Columbia scale okay and they
in terms you can think about these two
quadratic functions and the covariance
that joined the derivative is less than
the negative correlated among the random
variables okay
so in this case and the you proof plc is
nationally divided by y -1 so he just
natural number two points early
yes I understand the set of the
uncertainty second set of distributions
is all distributions with the same
marginals yes yes all distribution with
the same marginals so this is a certain
yeah the distribution with marginals and
you yes that's that this bomb we just
used to join the distribution so so this
is a bank for certain tenor to fail many
many stochastic complet orientation and
the uncertainty in the lack of demand
for facility location you can prove what
is the supper watching then what's the
super modular super jelly base can reach
to a large POC so it's just a reverse
they are positively correlated all the
random variables you think about a
continuously okay so you sure we can
show by example respond to two to the
power and the small n is the number of
uncertainty dimension around something
so so that gives you a classification
what problem have a small PLC so you can
use stochastic about a lakh machines and
all these constraints you can prove and
is actually and sub modulus okay you can
reduce this to even some simplified to
simple convex optimization problems and
deterministic problems you can apply to
any any norm so I'm going to go through
quickness just a couple of occasion to
show it is possible okay okay so we have
a sub modular we have a small PLC okay
how large is this turret heavy can be
expanded so can you expand for example
to fractional sub additive functions or
even to sub active functions at the
functions F express why always never
have X plus FY those kind of things okay
so so we basically converted this it
turned out and you cannot say too much
the unsub modular okay so we need to get
a very good during the distribution so
you can prove this is great the square
root of n if it's only of septum sub
modular even fraction s up you know you
can also construct example to see it's a
POC it is great so yes I'm going to come
back to their questions and yes so can
wait a little bit expanded to this so
this come from these so called the beta
approximate cost sharing functions so in
that case this is a function which is
defined by economists and in terms the
fair game in the bargaining game so they
have certain functions won't see the
code the beta approximation cost
assuring I'm going to give different
that definition did with later on then
the beta is characterized how much the
beta it is so if a beta equal to one
this very good beta sharing functions
whether you can prove is for any of
these type of functions you can prove P
or Z is 2 times beta so what's the
sister cost a monotone caustic series
basically say you can't think about the
C 1 C and a different agent so they have
these cost functions okay
can this custom function be charged to
participant of one independently it's
like a sum up of these cost functions
such that the I participant the eyes
charge the pay should it be decreased as
the demand for other participant
increase so this user dakota Farrelly's
of the bargaining game for submerge the
function is just called charge the
marginal cost when you charge marginal
cost the cost added up could be more
than the function itself cost function
itself so that's the beta magnifier
which you thought about so if you be
able to find a such function satisfies
those poverty you want to start on a
beta which is more as possible so
basically can we use conveniently
approximate those cost functions to each
C well C and so yes this is a basically
many many stochastic optimization you
can prove and some functions do have a
three proximate okay cost a Sharon to
approximate cost Sharon and then once
you have that we can prove PLC is less
than 2 times beta okay yes so this is a
ok also it's more time the betas you're
in basically POC is less than two beta
so in this case you know we have to
proof this you can safely assume demand
are independent in the facility location
problems then POC should be less than
six for some other popular standard for
rest and the network design problems
beta is less than two this is also it
turn out this beta function can be also
provided
bang so I'm not going to the Kotov says
yes for photo modular function you can
proof POC also lower bounded by e
divided by u minus 1 so that's what the
relate to so many many through these
conventions fascinating can prove VOCs
currency standard is greater than 2 so
there was some gap between 3 and 6 and
the 2 times 4 but just different pair
constant factors so that can be used for
POC also have a lower back okay so there
was also application to some distant
monistic upon prove this bound is tight
okay and so I'm going to go through very
fast okay so I'm give a quick summary of
this points of correlations or
correlation gap ok basically
characterized risk a social assume
independence in any any stochastic
optimization problem because we know any
of this problem is the balance between
the solution quality and also
solvability attractive or not this is
one thing but however we can up a bounty
they use poverty of attractive functions
so many of reporting you can do
structure analysis northeast function
satisfies certain properties of course
there were still many many open
questions okay here and only use
marginals okay is there any additional
information should be and some
correlation information should be used
should I use a broccoli was independent
and some one group kind of partition
variable integral group and each group
who may have a joined the distribution
but overall each group independence
so just expanded here and so completely
independence so the question is can we
how that dependent and the block size
understand anyway so and so this is
still some people analyze this so I
don't know how much time I have
Sebastian
five minutes on 25 good good okay
finally I'm talk about a nine in E and a
Dan
so this is all related to problems which
is solving any program problems which
the unknown distribution okay here I'm
you see use a very very simple examples
I and you know I'm teaching the
management of science and somehow I have
to use some very elementary exam for the
news rate what's the concept so there
was a fairy there was you yourself goods
products okay so with a fixed a certain
period number bias which is you know
they will fix the inventory of good
customer come a choir band of goods and
on the bid for certain prices okay then
your decisions sell not to eat not to
sell to each individual or you still
want to maximize revenue okay so this is
the one examples suppose you have some
goods to sales okay this is a current
how much item you have in the store okay
so the customer coming and talk about in
these bid models if he said I would buy
one pair one pant okay when shoes and
one hat okay I'm willing to pay $100
okay second a bit comes okay as they
said one just one t-shirt or one of my
house and bid for $30 okay so you
basically say should I order these
speeds or not if I what is this okay a
bit I collect $100 of course my in a
very reduced by one accordingly so
what's this
this is packing problems once you if you
collect all the bits you can decide so
for zero one linear integer programming
problems and stuff then we decide which
one to give which were not to be
basically this problem okay so this is
the user code that you can use LP
relaxation you know if you have one
so this each of this variable between 0
and 1 continues the LP relaxation of
course in practice you have to you can
even if you have LP
solution come hard from point A 9 then
you can just a flip the way you can
randomly decided on the point if I mean
Peter X once the probability is to sell
stuff ok so you can put this and
so-called offline and the linear packing
problems and you maximize PI T X T PI T
are those dollars a bit ok AIT basically
is a 0 or 1 indicate which item is
interested ok excuse you decision
variable is the one you can relax this
so this is LP problems however now we
consider a stream line verging or online
merging of these problems ok
your only lobby which is how much items
inventory at a very beginning ok let's
say you also know overall how many
customer will eventually come to the
store you have actually met could it be
time length could be excavated ok
you only know this information you don't
know any any part in PI T Arg ok
information revealed sequentially yeah
correspond to objective coefficient so
cheese information including the PI skip
a and AIT you do and you once you had
you have to make a you revoke post
decisions say or not to say
so many people use opt come from certain
distributions and yet he maybe have
certain patterns you study information
then we solve stochastic virgin but here
we want to be distribution free there's
no information hai tu and AIT so the
question is can you still how to
maximize this raven
so how was formalized with AIT is
between zero and one you can always
scale corner scale roles to make it
happen which is of some party is greater
than zero there was no much distribution
stochastic information related to the
bit data the other thing we assume is
there arriving around them I don't know
they are fixed but it's little for me
you can just Roy it they arrived around
and it whatever you just don't want them
to be yeah I want them to be at a sorry
that's correct because if you want to
sort the other services now see you can
do whatever so if you have an easy
pricey using sale policy they put all hi
Peter in the end if you have a hard
sales policy at the beginning they put
all high bidder and in the beginning so
there's not much you can say about these
problems so the only thing I'm going are
some minor surgeries I can run manage or
them with all the replacement
okay so hey state when you find this LP
maximum value by any given a and a pie
they are here suppose I know them I can
solve of nine problems so that's my
maximum revenue okay now if I have an IR
grams I coded this a magnitude BC
comparative if my revenue under these
algorithms average over all the possible
permutations its greater equal to C
times these offline LP values that make
sense no this is upper bound there was
not so you can do about this so you just
hope a C would be very very close to one
more level so passions what kind of
conditions you come so C as approval
body close to one so what kind of are
nine packing problems
which is can be use this online platform
to sell goods rather than just code call
arching is not clear
okay so the problem is how to learn nice
to see you will have hope how how we
come to parties competitive or ratios so
this is a of a slot distribution rather
than just take all the possible
permutations I'm going to introduce a
one numbers Scott B is the minimum among
other BI if you remember was the BI the
I is just the initial inventory are you
- good
okay
so here's the theorems yes every time
here I'm going to this is already
normalized in some sense so be ice or
normalizing that's good question yes
yeah you can always KPI but here we
assumed a the largest number in a
normalized each each row is already
scale level it's correct well any any
epsilon P 10 0 1 so there was no online
algorithm for solving this linear
programming which achieve competitive
ratio C 1 minus epsilon if B is less
than or M divided by epsilon square so
this is an active result what is the M
Amster number of goods so this is a
comparator options
the positive side where's my epsilon
comparative online rooms if B squared R
M log and divided by epsilon so you just
forget log term so I am divided by
Epsilon
this tool for any any and an absolute
square so this is a universal constant
so basically say what's the basically
say if one of the inventory is very low
it cannot achieve this one minus Epsilon
in the worst case because we don't know
any distribution however if if if I've
if item each item after normalization
you have enough inventories yeah you can
do and you can achieve one minus epsilon
and still there are nine decisions
okay so I'm a little confused way this
result is actually you don't want to
state it that something which is uniform
in here and a and B one right so yeah uh
hear you say assumes you have this so I
would when you wrote this I was
expecting to see something that was
depending exactly on the sequence of a
and pies that you would see right that
would be a motivation to actually fix
them ahead of time and then just work
with the permutation but but the result
you have seems to be uniform in those
guys no this is a this is this is
exactly I don't know I don't know any
information about a a on a pie so that
your your bound does not depend on
either what a is what is correct only
only on the six consumed only it depend
on B that's the only information you
know in advance the quantity of B I only
know these informations only know these
informations I know what's the total
number of these
that's the only information you know
about it okay so besides that app I
could be some pipe very small some pipe
very big okay but only thing I'm gonna
assume is they arrive at a random waters
so I want have precise the one that
state my result keep in the Omni and B
which is the decision if it's the
information knowing in advance
otherwise you don't know anything okay
so every simple stone to these
conditions so initial inventories so
this again this this ratio is so you can
you can't is I'm an ability from the
eighty and melody from the pie okay it's
not assume I can draw randomly make
these decisions okay so that's why my
initial value is deep so this is a for
all the possible a and a pie yes I'm not
saying all for certain a and a pie and
this problem is good and one of this
works for all the possible a and a pie
it's not as a satisfies this condition
and pie satisfy these conditions in the
power of versions for integral versions
this is for indigo so my reference so
you have you even so this is integral
decisions revenues so this is a
continuous version
so you know see cannot be equal to one
you already has to be have some
sacrifice but here is incorporated into
the information so you know so the proof
is very is for full acting result is
likely you have m equal to 1 if they
have an inventory level P you can
construct a instance of P T which is
equal to B and it will be lost square
root of B so you were never there was no
algorithms and you always you always
have a lost piece so this is one square
root of the be so so what happened so
this is already known it's nice this
animation cut 1 this is the secretary
problem but here it's constant event so
the proof technique is constructed zis
and it's basically say canvas separators
ease into log M rather independent the
problems ok so then and if you can
simplify each up for each you have a log
M separable problems each one have
optimal values ease then you can
guarantee you have a loss which is 1
minus squared log M square root of B so
look and B that would be you know about
so it's problem is how to split a
comparator auction properly into log and
so basically you're basically have is
some kind of a master to sell and the
items is become a packing problems okay
so this is a must-have item in order to
achieve sense then you feel the another
one like you know normal items such that
they've basically filled up and into
equal to B so you it's lower than they
basically give you those agram you can
achieve this so divided into B log and
and then you just feel some other small
items or some orders okay how to proof
positive result it's very constructive
okay again among people's all the talk
is how to
decision optimization model which in
which where distribution is not know
okay so this is again we want to use so
there was no information available so
you cannot use backward okay so you have
to use some kind of online algorithms
which we call the nanny based especially
when you then you have to also do okay
so what are you on then the problem
would it be easy if there was some kind
of idea prices for each item
okay let's say this is idea some
magically I know this is a very good
price for each items so when the first
account I know the item nice the price
so these three add up
45 45 15 that's 105 105 and his bid is
hundred I reject if this guy buy two
items t-shirt $10 and the has 15 by 25
or things and he willing to pay $30 then
I say yes early understand this okay
online decision now once you know
somehow ideal okay prices thus that
price exists
yes exist once you collect all the
orders you solve these linear
programming realizations you find out
what's the do multipliers which you need
a program will call the shadow prices
you can prove that shadow price would it
be ideal prices the questions you come
through zero one you still need to all
the information or the computers or
shadow prices now what do we do when
then those prices using arrived the
information where let me make sense ok
so this is what we coat and any a grams
okay so and the price and be written if
no the P star then you can do so
basically we basically approximate and
we lenses shuttle price do they have a
concentration can they be long a ball or
something okay this is a so-called
one-time in any immigrants basically and
I have epsilon think about is one
percent okay you have a negative in the
beaters and n so first 100 you don't do
anything
it's just observe the data once you
observe data you use so you can use this
as a sample the formulate a small sample
in a programming hopefully very close to
the population linear program programs
then users that price small sample
linear program shadow price for your
future decisions okay okay
so this is a very yeah so this is what I
said and PZ loss so how much is then you
solve a small linear part of an inner
program problem instead gives them full
resources you give some epsilon percent
of resources
you forget it is 1 minus epsilon sins
that make sense
still XTP turns yellow and the one
that's my sample problems yes yes yeah
I'm give a little bit and smaller that's
because in the proven techniques I need
to there was this action mater is not
unbiased so killers unbiased xm8 I gave
a little bit 1 minus epsilon times the
absolute so instead the exactly 1% of
resources are located this one percenter
customers a gives them need a bit less
but the overall idea is because I assume
random for mutated right it's the first
100 dollars it'll be a good
representation I don't know need a pipe
but it's good one percent those one
percent customer popular consumer 1
percent a resource so I just give them
one percent per source I solve that for
shadow price
the ends of residues which is easy so
that's one time learning you can prove
again I'm only faced in my condition and
be okay
I'm longer any any possible a and a pipe
okay so this is M log n divided by
epsilon cube
in terms am it's the you know this is M
so in time epsilon this is not optimal
because all the lower bar indicate
depend on epsilon should it be epsilon
square can wait Shiva epsilon square yes
this is the coded dynamic learning that
I'm going to skip the proof idea of nine
proof okay so this is so called dynamic
convenience okay
why not you're updating your price so
and if a times epsilon n you computing
your sample linear programming you use
that a price X decision after you can a
to epsilon customers to 100 comes use
that available data so of a slightly
larger size than linear program problems
a mixer update and a for epsilon so I'm
going to the updated at this topper to
and power to face so basically I'm give
there and each of this L this pays and
gives these proportional resources again
discount a little bit to kill the bias
and this option is close to the epsilon
square two and abettor L I will take
epsilon into epsilon and for epsilon and
the power to pace once we update the
price we use this so you can see we
compute the initial price when you start
price to make an online decision after
you get it to epsilon and we compete on
your shuttle price and we use this and
just for the rest of the case
so this is a pasta so paste so then what
do we do we we do stage 2 epsilon square
which is optimal in terms that depend on
the absolute
okay so I like this result because and
the shows which reasonable people
probably doing in practice you know why
not just went in one time you saw you
once you're so many more sample more
sample data cons okay so again this is
the time so I'm just giving a little bit
of history of these problems we post
lower bound upper bound so for m equal
to one is good okay
there were some other on specific
betting problems which you need to opt
greater than C's which you can get one
minus Epsilon competitive ratios there
was paper and boss needed to be greater
than epsilon 3
okay paper I talked about it today is
based on this 2010 walk so M log n
epsilon square if you still remember
forget this log term our lower lower
bound is log M divided by epsilon square
if it is less than that you cannot do
that
however this gap so there was another
piece of work
in the following three pieces work it
happened in the next couple years it
turned out our lower bound is tight you
only need to be greater than log M
divided by M star I'm just only the some
more term or constant
okay so this is more like one time than
in so this is you know that this
including the secretary bodman is a
special case so one time mostly is the
epsilon cube I said that hammock
learning that's what we did okay
there was extension to this one but here
I'm fully dynamic a star what's the
dynamic a star actually the update is
the price in some sense the up the price
every time every new order comes from
level okay so we're order and this power
tool where update those price only as is
power to so part of some sense they
updated more freely
so in some sense the lower boundaries
out upper panel result so this result
only depend on B looks for any a on a
pipe okay and so it works okay yes okay
I'm just quickly so this is a we're also
working on the so called the price
posted any Jamaat oh I talk about is the
bid price the customer beautiful certain
price the seller decided to sell in
order to sell but in most real cases is
the Sailor decide what's the price and
then watch where the consumer buy or not
to buy okay so in those kind of things
can you still do something so here I'm
just quickly assume there was a lot of a
assume distribution some Houston America
programming and but here what we did we
just assumed rivals persona but however
above a rate which is depending on the
price you post it so the questions when
then we needed to lens its function
values to some shot this is non
parametric search we'd only assume the
arrival rate function have any specific
form so basically we build a similar
things with
achieve the optimal and any rate yeah
time so basically you have a regret rate
so we basically achieve we graduated
with some minus 1/2 which considered to
be the optimal ones so I'm going to okay
so basically is our brain is basically a
poster several price so you can think
about these is the section again you
have a geometrical page to update to try
your different price then the confidence
intervals the optimal price is getting
narrow narrow narrow finally you can a
very narrow price and so such nothing
that would it be surprise you an end ok
so some rate okay on this online
optimization necessary and sufficient no
again but however as you said maybe if
we assume a and a PI have a certain
patterns may be this rate can be
enormous so this is not going to be a
lower balancing an eye on a very general
class of nonlinear its distribution free
or for the price posting its
nonparametric okay so I particularly
wanted to advocate this dynamic learning
okay
even this is one time sales but you can
still break into multi period so you
then from the observe the data so we
could any well decisioning do something
we still don't know whether this can be
true for and buy and sell okay
market so right now the item maybe
montaner okay so right now I only sell
things but maybe presumably somebody go
to platform wanted to sell some good to
me as the market maker should I accepted
those bids or not okay so then this
would be truly
linear program programs so can you still
say something okay
and also Marty item pricing term
more general online optimization so
where we basically found out an
endocrinology optimal knock 90 much
prion and the shadow price seems the
good things and Mister we have a target
on in okay okay so I think yeah I think
that's that's all I wanted to say yeah
thank you yeah
[Applause]
yeah yes
sup modular function that's cost sharing
functions called beta yes for that one
for for submerged the function is not a
beta equal to one
as correct we hope at least a week we
want to prove even yes we want to prove
and the beta of any base that we have a
year divided by Y minus 1 beta
algorithms but right now we're only
provable for - that's correct yeah so
yes that's why for submerge the function
you have a nest at your objective
coefficient C its uncertainty is time
UTC variable so that's as already beta
equal to 1 correct correct it is like
it's like is so original we use this
kind of a double to power tool because
we're afraid so if an inner program is
to custody from practical consent each
time you make a decision you have to say
solve every increase in size and inner
part but turn out that the shadow price
can be updated in some sense is just use
the coordinate and some kind of a decent
ogron's - in that case given the
previous price as the initial point is
just update basically you only have one
data point added to the problems correct
yeah just update is at a price you note
that's not the major concern it's
computation is also super efficient
that's yeah very good
coming okay thank you